[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
وما حدث بالفعل
كان منذ اللحظة التي تم فيها إنشاء
Twitter ، أصبح هذا الشيء هو الذي بدأ في
تغيير العالم
وانطلق فورًا وبمجرد
أن أصبح  تبلغ قيمتها مئات الملايين من
الدولارات ثم مليارات الدولارات ،
انتهى الأمر بكل واحد من الأصدقاء الأربعة إلى
دفع بعضهم البعض خارج الشركة
واحدًا تلو الآخر
[موسيقى]
شكرًا
لك ولكن الآن في 2005-2006 كان لدينا رسالة قصيرة
يمكنني بالفعل إرسال رسالة نصية قصيرة  رسالة من
Uh Singular إلى Verizon مفادها أنه كان
جديدًا جدًا في الولايات المتحدة
وكنت أعشق التكنولوجيا التي
تعرف أنها تتحلل بأمان إلى
كل جهاز حتى أرخص الأجهزة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[  الموسيقى]
الأجنبية
[الموسيقى]
الجزء الأجنبي [الموسيقى] كان ملزمًا حيث
سيتم إصلاح الجزء الصعب الآن كيف
يغير النظام الأساسي لحرية التعبير
هل تسمح لترامب بالعودة إلى ما
يقطعه الرأس  تبدو مثل هذه أ  إعادة
بعض الأسئلة التي
سيجيب عليها المسك النهائي خلال الأسابيع القادمة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية